im Moment geht es bei den
Koalitionsverhandlungen ja noch vor
allem um Inhalte aber schon bald wird es
um Posten gehen und da habe ich eine
ganz besondere Anforderung an die
zukünftigen Ministerinnen und Minister
ich fordere eine elternquote für die
nächste Regierung und das vor allem aus
zwei Gründen zum einen glaube ich dass
viele Fehler die in der corona-politik
begannen wurden nicht gemacht worden
wären wenn Merkel sparen Scholz Altmaier
wenn sie Kinder gehabt hätten es gab so
viele
sensationelle verrückte Regelung bei
denen sich viele Väter und Mütter
gefragt haben hat die Spitze des Staates
überhaupt noch einen Bezug zu Realität
wir leben ja zum Glück in einer
Gesellschaft in der auf Vielfalt und
Diversität eine große Rolle gelegt wird
wir haben für allesquoten Frauenquoten
aufsichtsratquoten Milchquoten warum
also nicht auch eine elternquote
Deutschland ist schon jetzt das
kinderärmste Land Europas die sind in
den letzten Jahren immer weiter
zurückgegangen und ich fürchte dass
dieser Trend sich weiter verschärfen
wird wenn wir nicht endlich die Familien
mehr in den Fokus rücken ich frage mich
ob die Familien noch zu einer größeren
sind noch zu einer kleineren Minderheit
zusammenschrumpfen müssen bis man sie
endlich schützt warum ich noch für eine
Quote sehen wir in der zweite Grund ist
wer eine Familie hat der lernt
Haushaltsführung
Arbeitsteilung der lern-effektiv zu sein
der lernt zuzuhören der lernt Demut und
vor allem lernt er Verantwortung für
sein eigenes Handeln
und Verantwortung für sein Handeln und
das ist etwas was ich bei Politikern im
Moment tatsächlich vermisse und ich
glaube wir Kinder hat die müssen noch
mehr daran gelegen für eine lebenswerte
Zukunft zu kämpfen kurzum Eltern sind
die besseren Politiker
ich finde das ein sehr guten Vorschlag
wir haben ja lange genug erlebt dass es
eine batte über die Kinderrechte im
Grundgesetz gab das ist ja voll
beschriebenes Papier und nützt überhaupt
nichts ist ja auch nicht zustande
gekommen weil es zu obscore ist da sage
jetzt keiner noch eine Quote nee nee das
ist ja das können sich ja die Parteien
selbst setzen dieses Ziel die SPD setzt
sich ja zum Ziel dass die Hälfte ihrer
Minister Frauen sind und genauso gut
kann sie sagen für sich selber und die
Hälfte mindestens unserer Minister hat
Kinder oder ein Kind ist Elternteil kann
man sagen steht jedem frei und das finde
ich sehr richtig weil das geht doch
sozusagen über das Frau sein hinaus da
hat man noch eine ganz andere
Lebenserfahrung und ganz andere Aufgaben
und man ist ich bin ja selbst Vater von
zwei Töchtern
da wird das Leben erst rund mit Kindern
wird das Leben und vorher hat man nicht
richtig gelebt hat man vielleicht
aufregen gelebt und
aber erfüllt lebt man erst mit Kindern
und solche Leute möchten in der
Regierung haben aber was ist also man
muss jetzt ich bin total gegen Quoten
also dementsprechend das wäre für mich
fürchterlich wenn das was eben nicht zu
Dir
also ich würde niemals eine gesetzliche
Quote dafür wollen vor allem weil ich
auch immer glaube man darf auch nie
vergessen es gibt auch viele Frauen in
Deutschland die uns einfach auch nicht
vergönnt ist Kinder natürlich kommen
natürlich ganz schwere Schicksale und
wenn man jetzt noch so Quoten einführt
ist ja wirklich so so als müsste man es
noch mal zeigen jedem so Gott du kannst
es ja nicht wie schlecht du du bist
nicht rund das Leben fängt nicht an denn
deswegen das sind die zwei Punkte was
ich aber noch ergänzen will wir haben
dass wir aber eigentlich von Yvonne
Wissen Angela Merkel hat ja keine Kinder
Olaf Scholz hat ja schon in seinen 20ern
wenn ich es richtig gelesen habe es gab
ein porträte in dem Spiegel da schien es
mir so als hätte er das als Entscheidung
getroffen keine Kinder zu bekommen und
sich ganz der arbeitswidmen
die Parteien für sich auf sich anders
können die Parteien natürlich tun
es gibt 11,6 Millionen Familien in
Deutschland das ist das ist nicht wenig
aber wie gesagt es wird immer weniger
und ich sehe das Problem es war
unfassbar was im letzten Jahr
von Kindern verlangt wurde was von
Eltern verlangt wurde es gab es gab
Regelungen wo wo meine Freundin wo
andere Väter wo wir gedacht haben haben
sie das jetzt wirklich so entschieden
wenn also ich und mein Mann wir arbeiten
beide Vollzeit wir sollten aber unseren
Sohn ich habe zwei Kinder fünf und neun
also eine in der Kita die war dann
geschlossen mein Sohn 9 hatte
Homeschooling wochenlang wie sollen wenn
zwei Eltern arbeiten und nicht jeder war
ein Kurzarbeit und nicht jeder kann home
also ich bin Reporterin ich musste
draußen rumrennen und das mache ich ja
auch gerne aber wie soll man
gleichzeitig aufs Kind aufpassen 5
Stunden unterrichten mindestens 8
Stunden arbeiten mein Mann hat teilweise
abends um 23 Uhr angefangen zu arbeiten
ja weil wir das gar nicht anders
abdecken können und das ging über Monate
und Monate hat Kinder und es war der
strikteste Start Bayern er hat Kinder
also Markus Söder wäre jetzt für mich
total das Gegenargument das ist nicht
besser gewesen wäre wenn die Kinder
gehabt hätten weil Markus Söder zum
Beispiel hat nicht mein Freund von mir
also nicht eher aber der durfte oder ich
glaube aber die sind auch nie die Gefahr
gekommen ist deine Kinder selbst zu
betreuen ehrlich gesagt Gymnasium ja
aber dann musst du dich nicht mehr die
ganze Zeit kümmern gute für kleinere
Kinder damit genau
23 jährige Schwester würde auch nicht
mehr sehen das heißt meine Eltern hätten
jetzt gar keine Quote mehr erfüllt mit
mir mit 29 und meiner Schwester mit 23
was heißt wir brauchen eine Quote
Unterteilung ja was sagen sie dazu
ich möchte jetzt mal von den von den
Kindern
das ist ein Bereich ich würde mir
wünschen dass wir Ministerinnen und
Minister haben die mal wieder Anruf vom
Fach haben genau wie wir argumentieren
und sagen die sollten Kinder
sein naja da würde ich mir wünschen dass
die in Politiker juristisches Fachwissen
mitbringen oder im günstigsten Fall
sogar noch Polizei das haben sie ja alle
die von der von der Straße abgekommen ja
Polizei und noch viel mehr
Verteidigungsminister
ja wenn da mal wieder einer säse der
aussieht der weiß wie ein Soldat
aussieht und was der macht ist aber ich
persönlich denke ja auch dass ein
Verteidigungsminister beim Bund gewesen
sein sollte aber vielleicht ist es eine
naive Verständnis
nicht so
aber sie hätte es gerne
aber die Hand will ich nicht dafür ins
Feuer lesen ich glaube der Rühe war
nicht bei der Bundeswehr und der war
Verteidigungsminister das galt damals
auch als
fortschrittlich weil da kommt einer rein
der war ja auch kein schlechter
Verteidigungsminister das muss nichts
heißen aber nur von jemand operiert
werden der es gelernt hat also ich finde
auch Justin todo zum Beispiel in Kanada
der das wesentlich besser gemacht das
System da haben die Minister wirklich
alle Ahnung die wurden genauso besetzt
da ist natürlich der
Verteidigungsminister jemand der sehr
hoch gedient hat ich finde Justin todo
ist da definitiv ein Vorbild wenn man da
Hinblick und da bin ich auch bei dir
Yvonne gegen die Quote aber da bin ich
bei dir ich finde wenn Soldat die müssen
ja dienen und beim Soldaten ist eine
krasse Hierarchie bis nach oben und
plötzlich kommt der höchste Chef und war
noch nie bei der Bundeswehr Annegret
Kramp-Karrenbauer hat nicht gedient
Ursula von der Leyen hat nicht gedient
für mich wäre es auch völlig fallen wenn
es eine Frau wird die aber mal bei der
Bundeswehr war aber es gibt Aussicht
darauf dass es jetzt einen gibt der da
war er Lars Klingbeil SPD
Generalsekretär stammt sogar aus einer
Soldatenfamilie und er war im
Verteidigungsausschuss hat ist also ein
doppelter Hinsicht
oder da ist mir ziemlich wurscht ob das
der SPD kommt oder sonst woher der
versteht einfach was davon und das das
haben die Soldaten auch verdient genauso
wie die Polizei verdient hat dass dann
Innenminister sitzt der der nicht nur an
Bayern denkt und an seine Karriere in
der CSU
warum machen
[Musik]